[Applause]
well my cast and crew please come up run
run run run run run run I want you up
here with me please
this took a village as many of you know
it takes a village to make a film like
this and I first want to say praise God
for this this has been a 10-year journey
for me almost 10 years almost a decade I
caught wind of a an orphanage that was
posing as a Catholic orphanage where the
the nun was allowing foreign men to come
in and sleep with the children and I
have taken years as my parents know
going back and forth investigating this
and then I took that footage and it got
me into USC and was at USC where I was
encouraged by friends and faculty to
turn it into a fiction narrative film
and it this is Lalo's house and I want
to say one thing that is so moving to me
is that to all the students who are here
today can I hear you if you're a student
in school right now I sat in those same
seats last year and I watched the
phenomenal films that the Academy has
allowed us to - given us a platform to
be able to show our art and I want to
see you up here next year okay I am
going to go in chronological order since
it's a 10-year process of all the people
who have helped me over the years my mom
and my dad Beth Chapman and dr. Dudley D
Chapman I I love you I don't see where
you are I think you're over here
somewhere okay I am so thankful to you
for believing in me when things didn't
seem like they were panning out this is
a testimony to perseverance everyone
everyone it doesn't matter if you're a
filmmaker doesn't matter what you do if
you have something in your heart and it
is pressing you you keep going because
now I'm standing up at the Academy yeah
and and and to have your family and
friends around you who encourage you it
is everything and I have to continue to
thank my aunt Pat and my entire family
who's over here and jada jada in triva
Mike's my church family that's over
there too
the people who first helped me get to
Haiti when I started doing this J
lamothe Tiffany Steen Marilyn Payne the
peen family the de soos family my Rhodes
family they didn't help me to get to
Haiti but they are my husband's family
and I love them thank you my mentors at
USC michael taylor bruce block Michael
Fink Brenda Goodman Dean Daley and all
of the faculty who are here today who
really encouraged me and believed in me
on the Sydney Institute in Haiti which
is one of the best film schools it's the
only film school in Haiti right now but
now you see how they can help make an
academy winning film so please continue
to support them my co-producer Victor
for sell well you guys just wait yes my
co-writer Yasmin yola's my editor Jeremy
didn't know my DP Chiang Mai ding my you
guys i obviously you see I have a lot of
people so I'm not going to go through
all the names my executive producers and
actress who played the villainous
character in there she is the sweetest
thing it's like the nicest people play
the greatest villain sir Garcelle
Beauvais and Lisa L Wilson for believing
in me and lifting me up on their
shoulders and telling me to reach higher
I thank you so so much I also have to
thank their loving friend Jamie Foxx who
have yet to meet
okay okay who also believed in women
filmmakers and I have to say this is the
time we are seeing some great changes
and as a community
men women just internationally people of
color of everyone we're coming together
and we're you can see the positive
changes that are happening in the
Academy they are directly reflected in
the Student Academy Awards look at the
diversity of these fantastic filmmakers
and I am so thankful that we all are
working together for positive change it
is it moves me so much
Marcel Jones Howard green Ephraim Walker
who helped connect me to these lovely
ladies Paul O'Brien I know I messed up
your name I'm trying I really am but who
did the beautiful music Jimmy Jean Louie
Jasmine Jean the week here they are the
babies they're the stars of the movie to
their mother Evelyn who let me borrow
them and take them to Haiti - okay I
just want to thank my entire crew who's
here today and anyone who's here from
Lalo's house who supported donated
helped painted whatever could you please
stand up so I can just applaud you I
love you and thank you and to the
Haitian community who has supported us
and believed in us and most importantly
to my husband Brian Vincent Rhodes
hey you five bang I love you so much I
am so proud of you we met at the
University of Southern California Thank
You USC tuition is worth it
and to Sean Hector Randi Greg everybody
at the Academy who has made this happen
who get who's given us a platform to
show that child trafficking human
trafficking is a real thing and it is
not just a Haitian issue it is a global
issue and it is right here and it's
something that we all need to be
concerned about and I am just so
grateful that you gave us this
opportunity to have this platform and I
just love you thank you
[Applause]